hello everyone welcome to the active
inference live stream it is active
inference Liv stream 11.2 on December
29th 2020 this is our last group active
inference live stream of the year so
thanks so much everyone who is out here
today and also um watching live for
those who are and I will share my screen
for the participants and here we
go Welcome to the active inference lab
everyone we are an experiment in online
team communication learning and practice
related to active inference you can find
us at our website on Twitter email
YouTube or our public keybase team and
username this is a recorded and an
archived live stream so please provide
us with feedback so that we can improve
on our work all backgrounds and
perspectives are welcome here and as far
as video etiquette for live streams mute
if there's noise in your background
raise your hands so that we can hear
from everybody on the Queue and we'll
use respectful speech Behavior as I
stated this is the last active inference
live stream for 2020 but in 2021 it's
already shaping up to be a great year
we're going to be meeting Tuesdays from
7: to 9:00 a.m. Pacific Time PST um or
Pacific time when the time changes and
you can go to this link to learn more
when you go to that link you'll see this
spreadsheet and it has instructions on
how you can participate as well as which
papers we'll be reading in which weeks
so uh you can see that many authors will
be joining us and hopefully everybody
will have the time to read and digest
these
papers today in active inference stream
11.2 we are going to have introductions
and warm-ups and then we'll go into the
112 itself we're going to be continuing
the discussion of sophisticated
affective inference the paper of hesp at
all 20120 welcome Sasha we'll run
through again the aims claims abstract
and road map and the figures
and Happy New Year's everyone thanks a
lot we'll do new stuff in 2021 and so
stick along let's get to the intros and
warm-ups we will introduce ourself just
by giving a short introduction or
check-in and then passing to somebody
who hasn't spoken yet so I'll start I'm
Daniel and I will pass it first to a
firsttime visitor
Scott hi I'm Scott David I'm at the
University of Washington Applied Physics
lab and I've been a lawyer for 27 years
I'm trying to use physics principles to
help structure social relationships and
I will pass it to
Stephen hello I'm Stephen I'm based in
Toronto I'm currently doing a
practice-based PhD with Canter Christ
Church University and I'm looking at
applying the dynamic processes of active
inference into my work with
participatory theater and Community
Development and helping to understand
the Dynamics of all of that and I will
pass it to
Ivan hello my name isan I in Moscow and
I'm a researcher in system management
School uh pass it to
Blue hello I'm blue Knight I am an
independent research consultant based
out of New Mexico and I will pass it to
Sasha hi um I'm Sasha I'm based out of
Davis California and um I study
developmental neuroscience and I will
pass it to uh
Alex hello my name is Alex I'm in Moscow
Russia I'm also researcher in systems
management school and I'm trying to find
a ways to connect active inference and
systems engineer
framework
thanks cool and Ryan uh it seems like
has the same situation as last week but
definitely for 2021 we'll figure it out
um I'll just tell them it still does not
work all right let's go to the warm-up
questions and again if anyone else joins
we'll just roll with it so for these
warm-up questions raise your hand it'd
be great to hear from everybody let's
just start off with what are some kinds
of agents that we might want to model in
active inference so just even before
reading this paper or after reading the
paper what was a kind of system or a
type of agent that we might want to
frame in this way of thinking so
emotions makes us think about individual
people but there's other kinds of
systems we might want to model as well
um actually Scott you were mentioning
some interesting uh types of Agents we
might be considering right before we
started so maybe could you pick up there
sure um I was mentioning in law it feels
like one of the things one of the
strategies is to introduce a provisional
agent a nominal party into an
interaction so if you have two people
interacting you can introduce a third by
introducing the third it changes the
system because it's now a three-party
system with three-party
concerns and that system then will have
a different markof blanket as I am
beginning to understand it and so in
that context you may be able to do
things you can't do in the other through
the other markco blanket because it may
be able to an example is in in tax
there's a thing called a like kind
exchange where I can exchange commercial
property for another commercial property
taxfree well very often you can't find
someone with exactly the property you're
looking for let's say you have a 20 Acre
Farm you want a 30 Acre Farm there's
nobody around with a 30 Acre Farm you
use an exchange facilitator and that
means there a third party in there they
take possession possession of both
properties and act like a mixing bowl
and so putting the details of that aside
it essentially changes that system so
changes your Markov blankets and so one
of the things I'm wondering about is the
intentional shifting of the Markov
blankets to increase solution
space cool so we have all kinds of
agents who are going to be interacting
and potentially by Shifting the
boundaries the interfaces between agents
and wrapping them or subpartitioning
them it's possible to make new kinds of
swaps um within existing infrastructures
or new ones so anyone can just raise
their hand I'll just put up the second
question which is another General one
which is how can we learn and
communicate the technical aspects of
active inference in an accessible
fashion Stephen go
ahead I don't know if I'm going to
explain how to do this but I'll explain
a challenge which um um but I think it's
important to overcome it because it's so
valuable is I was just in a conversation
and trying to talk about systems and how
we can how we think about systems when
we engage um in communities and thinking
about how we understand the world and
there's a lot of stuff in in in the
world of kind of the social arts and
participatory theater where it's like we
need to do something with the system and
then it flips to we're all a living
system and it's the body knows and we
just know how it is we just need to
listen to the body and it will know and
um it's both you know it's we're in this
Dynamic niche of which there's an awful
lot of stuff we don't know yet we can
tap into our body and the way that our
body works and there's a way that we
construct meaning in the world so I
suppose trying to find a way to take
case studies and show how it can help
would be really
useful um thank you
Sasha yeah um thanks Stephen I really um
agree with what you said and uh
ironically or I guess in a very meta way
um Act of inference is the answer to
that question because um through like
closing the loop and introducing action
into the system we can better understand
thinking about the system and so I I
think that's an really great point that
um case studies and uh really specific
applications of active inference are
going to be the best way to teach and
learn about it um so yeah I think that's
a great Point cool
blue so just to kind of piggyback on
that I think um and maybe tie in some of
what Scott was saying earlier uh when we
think about um modeling in active
inference it's interesting to think
about scaling this not in the way that
we talked about when we were talking
about scaling active inference but in
the way that like we have several
different systems even just existing
within the body right like the input and
output of the stomach and the spleen and
the liver and and you know also like the
brain and the the sematic awareness
right to speak to kind of what what
Stephen was saying earlier so it's
interesting to try to think about
modeling systems within systems in in
active
inference yep and actually this brain
and body uh dialogue and the multi
systems approach in the way that it
doesn't say well everyone told you the
brain was important actually it's the
body no it's actually it's both and
similarly it's like quantitative and
qualitative and so it's not just that
we're going to throw out one for the
other but we want to think across that
Division and integrate them that's the
Beyond internalism and externalism and
integrating The Sciences with the
humanities and other things that we're
kind of talking about
Scott I just put in the chat there was
an article that came out in December 4th
in Science magazine called the
exploitative segregation of plant roots
and so this is helps with that second
question uh learn communicating it what
it was talking about is the way that
plant roots grow specifically you have
two trees next to each other each has a
system each has a markof blanket they're
growing next to each other and they
differentiate their plant growth roots
to optimize statistically their nutrient
uptake and so they don't go and intrude
on other plants Roots space because that
would not be optimized for them because
they'd be putting more resources into
into growing further roots and and but
getting fewer nutrients because they'd
be nearer the other plant and so to me I
looked at that and I went wow that's a
real nice way to understand the Dynamics
of two different organisms interacting
with statistical gradients there it's a
nutritional gradient specifically that
felt to me like it was a nice way to
kind of introduce that idea of the of
the contact between the two different
systems cool so what I'm going to take
from this second question and all the an
to it is that through examples that are
accessible and at hand we can all start
to learn more about the relational side
of active inference and also the
statistical and the quantitative because
both those sides are going to be
learning Journeys for everybody because
no one's going to know all the
statistics no one's going to know all
the Deep relational pieces that are so
uh familiar to Performance artists and
other areas the last question on the
warmup is what is something that you are
wondering about would like to have
resolved by today's
discussion so one thing I'm wondering
about is um was raised right before we
started as well is like how do we think
about emotion or this parameter in
systems that aren't us and I'm also even
wondering whether the emotions we
experience are these parameters and how
do we name parameters or talk about
parameters of mathematical models in a
way such that they're recognizable and
capture meaning but also don't constrain
or sort of uh falsely limit what it
means to be that term so we can get into
a map territory issue when we're talking
about computational models of emotion
just like we could with Consciousness
blue so just to kind of piggyback on
what you were saying about um emotions
like I don't know as I'm starting to
study more about emotion like I'm a a
logic and science kind of researcher and
so but learning about emotion and just
reading personally a lot of it seems to
be like non-verbal right and so how do
you like quantify or even measure
emotion on a scale when it's it's really
like you know you're you're feeling some
you know primitive thing from you know
when you were left in your crib as a
child that you have no words for because
you didn't have words for it at that
time and so how do you kind of like like
impart some kind of meaning or
quantitative scale on something that
that maybe there's not even language for
yes it's almost like the uh discredited
but guiding three-part brain model so
it's like the most prefrontal is the
numbers in that level of formalization
and then a little bit lower we have
language but then below that the
substrate is actually experience and
that's the embodied experience that may
or may not even have words to express it
and then we can look at expressions like
poetry or speech and is there a way to
get more precise or is it merely an
expression that's arising from an
emotional state but the emotional State
isn't a number it's not a words it's
actually something that's more deep
Scott I was wondering if with regard to
dance and performance whether there are
ways of communicating because we talk
about embodied I wonder about encoding
so can emotions be encoded in dance in a
way that they can't be encoded in speech
or other movement so that it becomes a
surrogate or kind of that mirror neuron
idea that you're projecting out an
emotion by the projection of your body
position the morphology uh being the
encoding of the
emotion cool question yeah Stephen
definitely yeah I think this also
relates to this question of um affect
and dimensionality so maybe there's a
way that when we take a perspective on
things we kind of look at a dimensional
approach but it can be encoded in some
sort of
spatial um aect Ive way and maybe those
Dimensions aren't they they they become
like Dimensions but the encoding is is
not as linear as that a bit like color
space when we see colors the the space
of colors you can encode it in sort of
in in lightness and two different types
of color Dimensions but the way that
it's encoded is when people look at
perception it's not it's not linear in
that space so maybe there's like an
affect space which somehow encodes in a
in a way which is
n-dimensional so mate oh sorry go ahead
go ahead so might um
Aesthetics
be um
provisional um efforts at
encoding very nice to bring in the
Aesthetics and the intuition because
intuition is that which can't be
expressed it's sort of like the dark
matter it's the submerged part of
Iceberg but those reflect the deepest
priors potentially that help us search
through the state space that as we've
been exploring is vast to do the
exponential rollout of a chess game is
going to be hard it's going to be more
um basically States than you can keep
track of however if you think I feel
good about this uh arrangement of the
pieces then with just a simple affect
and a limited roll out you may be able
to do very well so again we're not sure
but we'll figure this one out okay uh
let's is that just one other thing is
that like the holographic principle
potentially that on a system the
information about the system is
displayed on its surface is a Markov
blanket potentially that surface that
you observe to understand the system
inside I believe so and Chris Fields who
will be coming onto the stream we'll be
talking about a paper that's going to be
uh in early March Chris has done a lot
of holographic marov blanket research so
let's keep on thinking about that cuz
that's very interesting I'm not exactly
sure but yeah hopefully we'll figure
that one out within a few months so the
paper itself and then again we'll have
enough time just to hear whatever people
are thinking but uh sophisticated
affective inference we talked about it
in 11.0 and 11.1 and the paper is about
combining these two previous threads of
research which were
sophisticated active inference which is
sophisticated meaning deep through time
with affective inference or active
inference where there's an emotional
state
component the abstract they state that
and the road map of this relatively
short paper is pretty short so today
let's think about how these two threads
which are distinct threads that's why
they each were their own paper can be
combined into something that is in front
of us today
which is this paper that is literally
sumting these two threads of research
and then we can think about a few
directions that this research makes us
think about whether developing more
advanced simulations so just asking
which parameters of the simulation could
be improved or how could this be
expanded or generalized but also on the
more functional side we can look to
computational Psychiatry because we're
talking about emotions if we are and
also even nonhuman agents like robots so
few different directions we can go and
to structure that
discussion it could be useful for us to
have a few examples like two or three or
four of sophisticated affective
inference agents conventional or
unconventional so certainly one of them
could be a person but we'll think of
that person being in a certain context
and then we'll return to these examples
that we come up with right now as we go
through the slides ahead we'll just
return it to example a BC and then when
we're talking about parameters we'll be
able to say okay so in the example a
this Matrix would represent this in the
example B it would represent that so who
has a thought or a suggestion on what
would be like a cool system to bring
into this mixture so again one of the
examples will be a person and people can
suggest what they think that person's
like story or situation should be kind
of like an improv scene and then also if
people want to provide uh an
unconventional uh system that'd be good
too
so any thoughts on
that
Alex um I think maybe we can consider
the next system scale and see on team
Behavior great and uh so try to Define
uh these uh Concepts in a meaning of
team communication inside and outside
communication with different
subsystem of
organization thanks for suggesting that
so let's do um example a is going to be
an individual human so that will be
hopefully grounding us to our lived
experience and to realistic situations
that people and comic book characters
find themselves in the second example B
is going to be team communication so
we'll kind of develop the story but
we'll see maybe the team is a startup
team or maybe they're a research team or
maybe it's uh just an affinity group
about some other topic and then the
third example let's think about
something more organizational and
institutional so let's think about that
third example being potentially like uh
a large company large enough to have a
legal department and an HR department
let's just say so we have three examples
which is going to be the person the team
and the institution SL Organization
three levels of analysis and then as we
walk through these formalisms let's see
where might be like strengths weaknesses
limitations insights Etc
Stephen and I suppose you could apply it
to all of those this idea you know we
have this vision and Mission I mean
that's more for an organization the
mission and the vision transfers down to
a team which might be the purpose and
the roles and then you've got the kind
of the character and the kind
of you know meaningfulness for the
individual so you've got this tempor
depth being sort of expressed across all
of those levels of scale yeah exactly
like the examples in this case they're
not three disjoint examples in fact the
individual could be on a team in an
organization so all three of these
examples that we're going to be talking
about could be nested within each other
or they could be disjoint and so that
really highlights why it's so important
to have a multiscale perspective because
even when we're talking about the
individual we're going to be thinking
about the individual it's the system of
Interest it's what we're talking about
it's the interface we're talking about
the marov blanket that we're talking
about but it's inherently embedded
within a larger system so we're not
going to forget the company when we're
talking about the individual and vice
versa so it's always all the scales
happening at once but then depending on
the system of Interest or the marot
blanket or the level of course graining
that is being uh performed in that
specific analysis it will uh will dive
into the details as they present
themselves but that will be kind of fun
so here's figure one in the paper and we
went a little bit in the previous videos
into some of these subcomponents because
this is like M4 and there's M12 3 as
well that lead up to M4 but just to
recap what each of these pieces are o at
the bottom is observation and S is the
state that inference is being done upon
so this is where those examples come
into play so in the individual case the
state that that something might be
having uh that an individual might be
performing inference on it could be is
it sunny or cloudy outside and maybe
that changes how you feel or it could be
a hidden State like is this person um
happy with me or sad with me um a is the
mapping of how the hidden States relate
to the observations so whether at the
individual level it's sunny outside and
then the observations are perceived with
certain
probability um and then yeah people just
raise their hand if they want to like
jump
onto another example or uh you know ask
a question about how some of these
variables might interact I'll just walk
through them with no example and then
we'll go to the example pieces B is how
the states are inferred to change
through time so the B is like the
probability that given that at State one
it was in such and such a state that at
the next time point it would be at a
different state now U is a piece that
connects to B and this is the policy and
so the policy is something that
influences how states are likely to
transform into each other the policy
itself is Downstream of the agents
decisions about uh which actions to
engage in it turns out that the way that
the action selection is chosen at the
level of analysis whichever blanket that
we're talking about that is uh action
selection Guided by this set of
parameters the G is that expected free
energy that's being minimized and that
also covers up the C Matrix which is
like the
preferences the gamma is the Precision
or the uncertainty whether it's like one
over or not and basically this relates
to how precise the agent believes they
are in their estimate of which policies
to be pursuing given this chain of
things happening down here a um is the
uh is the okay sorry about that at each
time point in this model because I want
to I want to General but I want to be
specific about what this model actually
did at each time point in this model
that's being captured by this top sort
of pinkish area this is the affect of
inference question where the affect of
the agent is uh relating into how it
simulates rolling out in this whole
internal Gray Zone all this these future
time points and um then each model tick
is going to be like moving from the left
to the right and at each time point in
this model the agent is going to be
running out some uh possibilities for
what could happen in the future so
Stephen and then we'll think about the
examples
yes sorry I was going to sort of bring
an example there so maybe go ahead go
ahead yeah um well one thing that's come
up and I I've been doing some work with
this metaphors of movement and Andrew
Austin who does that work he talks a lot
about how anxiety he finds anxiety is
often related to people having trying to
have elevated status like they're trying
to have an elevated status and it's and
it makes a lot of sense with this
because it could also be like you feel
like you put yourself in an elevated
status and you're always going to be
slightly uncertain unless maybe you're a
king or someone about that status being
maintained so being put on a pedestal
can be so there could be something about
Western society and Status which is
partly why we have this overarching
anxiety because
um and it would make sense in a way
because there's always a sense of never
being completely clear about whether
your status is going to be maintained so
I I thought that's kind of interesting
um and this would sort of tie would
support that kind of
observation yep so status or um various
other sort of social approval metrics we
can think of it's like the water we swim
in as social organisms so just like like
a company might be wanting to stay above
water financially at least that
department a person has to be staying
above water reputationally we can think
of it in that way and so again let's go
to the examples and think about these
different systems and what they might be
performing inference on
Scott just going to just going to
comment on the status U issue that it
feels like then you can adjust so you're
making serial adjustments right you're
trying to minimize the free energy
minimize the difference between your
expectation and the reality you're
experiencing as I understand it so with
that overall effective status you can do
what feels like compensating
controls so you could if you feel like
you're at risk Visa V the one
presentation you're making of self you
can rake in other presentations of self
to complement or supplement or mitigate
the impression of one of them because
because you have Myriad effective
projections that you're making
simultaneously so it feels like if you
have an awareness of this it can help
you with that presentation of self-
question by understanding that you okay
this effective status that I'm
presenting is not getting me where I
want to be inside so let me leverage
another one which is contiguous or a
neighboring affect I'll call it an
affectation here but I mean in a present
ation of a marov binding
site um so it feels like it gives a
strategy for hybridizing and
synthesizing your presentation of your
Markov blankets anyway keep going just
it's impressional yes okay so let's go
to the examples and think about how
these three potentially even overlapping
systems are going to be carrying this
out and an individual at each time point
maybe let's just say this is every
second or each minute a a team might be
interested in organizing on the
multi-day and the organization is going
to be more explicitly thinking okay
quarter to quarter that's going to be
our next time that we're going to do all
this simulation so it's not surprising
that as things get bigger they also get
slower so that's a common theme we're
going to see so the individuals affect
is really where this emotional
inspiration comes from so there there's
the closest mapping between affect and
emotion but let's think about that team
and the large company example well
affect again and veilance specifically
is like that plus to minus axis so is
this team going well is this company
going well and if someone says yeah
we're burning money at an incredible
rate it's unsustainable but it's going
well because I have a uh believed
trajectory that we're going to go on
where we actually pull out of the nose
dive and do XYZ so they can still think
it's going perfectly well even if the
instantaneous rate of loss is high and
then on the flip side you can imagine a
team or a large company where
instantaneously they're state looks like
it's good it looks like they have a lot
of cash or it looks like they have a lot
of people involved in the team but they
still feel negative about it so that
disjoint between the affect about a
situation and the state of the situation
is one thing to take into account now
let's connect the affect at all these
levels to Precision estimates at
different levels um especially in the
active inference framework which frames
what organisms or any system is doing as
Precision seeking high anxiety is going
to be coming from having low Precision
now it's not that we want zero um
uncertainty we want to have this
controlled novelty sort of U curve but
it can be clearly uh situations where
your Precision is too low and then
you're surprised by what is being uh
emitted to you in the niche whether it's
your team operating environment or the
company's operating environment and then
if your
Precision it can't get too high because
if you're overly precise and you're
incorrect then you're going to die like
if you have a super super accurate
understanding but you're just delusional
then you're going to fall off the cliff
so in a way what shapes this Precision
is actually the real world which prunes
beliefs that are not functionally
associated with success in the real
world Stephen and then we'll come back
to
it yeah I really like this um this idea
of of thinking about how we understand
ourselves within all of this so for
instance yeah if you could move between
a different regime of attention or sense
of self which could be like what happens
when we do sense making maybe even
change the operating metaphors of the
person you know who am I at the moment
you know what's the context what's my um
situational um Attunement what's my
team's purpose what's what's the
operating metaphor for this team are we
like all driving together in a car or we
are we building ourselves a fortress you
know and that would that almost could
give a way to jump in and out of these
kind of effective engines if that makes
sense so as you seen over time how's it
going what's the policy um and what's
the the affective States um that sort of
thought about in a certain future and
they could almost then say okay what if
I shifted maybe that's where You' need
the body like the metaphor I'm working
with and then what does that do and um
and maybe at times that's when you need
to work with the group to be able to do
that because maybe an individual can't
just keep flipping backwards and
forwards you need to work as a group to
do that kind of sense making across
different
times cool
Scott I had a question for Sasha you
were mentioning pruning but you weren't
talking about dendritic pruning but I
wonder if dendritic pruning is
describable by what the type of pruning
you were just talking about because my
understanding of dentritic pruning very
minimal is that you know during the day
you have the growth of dendrites and
then this pruned back
selectively um and that that is
influenced by your externality each day
the growth is influenced by your
externality and then there's this
pruning process that feels like it's
iterating itself at that at that level
is that describable by this here is that
another scale or is it something else
that's going on
there um yeah I think that's a really
interesting analogy that that's um kind
of what's happening there I I don't know
if I would uh kind of draw all the same
parallels um yeah just from a
mechanistic standpoint but it's true
that kind of in
the uh in the generalities that um uh as
connections are formed during the day
then
um they're pruned or lost um as they're
not used and yeah
we think that happens at night um but
yet I I think that's an interesting um
analogy to draw that it's uh beliefs
about the world that aren't
um I don't know useful or supported are
the ones that then get
pruned yes oh um I was also going to say
uh the other
aspect is I think we know uh from our
lived experience is that it's really
um it it's really interesting when
people can be uh holding certain beliefs
and not um not know that and then when
they finally kind of confront the the
belief
um it kind of yeah there's a bit of a
breakdown and um to me that that moment
is very interesting um when uh people
have to confront certain beliefs that um
maybe they didn't even recognize that
they held
so there's a phase change and a
recontextualization piece in the last
part you said Sasha and the pruning is
using a network analogy so it's like
pruning connections between different
aspects of the system and so let's think
about the individual in the uh office
having a conversation with somebody the
query the prompt to them let's just say
is how are you feeling and that is a
query that's presented to the interface
which is their ears and also their
vision and other aspects the query is
presented to the interface about what's
inside of the interface and now what's
happening inside of the interface is a
generative model of that query
presenting system so inside of the
person there's a generative model of for
example the person who's talking to them
asking that question and we know it's a
generative model because if they covered
up their eyes or if they only heard part
of it they might be able to still
recover what was being asked but in
either case there's a generative model
inside of the interface and a prompt is
being presented as an observation
stimuli to the interface that's querying
how the system will respond so speech is
action and that's not even uh a legal
claim it's that it's a motor claim
speech is generated by a motor Behavior
it's not your hand but it is a motor
behavior and for some people it is with
their hand so various body parts can be
used to communicate let's think about
that interface in the process of the
team and the company so potentially for
these organizational entities the
interface could be like a consultant who
interfaces with specific questions but
instead of a counselor who asks how are
you feeling to an individual there might
be questions that could be asked to the
team and there can be questions that
could be asked such that only the team
could respond and someone might say well
how could you ask a question that only a
team could respond to aren't teams
composed of people there's two things
I'd say there the first is that that's
the reductionist argument the
reductionist slide is like what do you
mean get a response from a person aren't
you just to get a response from skin
cells and neurons it's like right that's
what I'm trying to get that response so
even if the response can be
reductionistic understood as being
composed of smaller pieces that's not a
surprise that should be taken for
default so questions can be asked to
teams that of course humans are going to
be responding uh to as well but also we
can think about kind of like Colony
phenotypes we can think about team
phenotypes so for example let's just say
I ask a question to a team like uh what
did you have for lunch or what do you
think the most exciting project is for
next year and then I looked at the
distribution of how long it took people
to respond to that message that's like a
colony level trait it's a collective
trait that distribution is composed of
people acting but no individual can
dictate what that distributional
parameter is so it's like a measurement
of let's just say some blood cells you
flow a million blood cells through and
then you can get a distrib ution across
all of those blood cells so it's like
you're querying in the aggregate even
though each individual sub piece uh
could have been following that
distribution or uh somewhat of an
outlier so those are the kinds of things
that you could ask presenting to a team
or an organization and the team or the
organization is going to have a
generative model of its Niche so if it's
involved in a certain type of
consultancy where it paid a lot of money
and it really respects what the person
is going to be uh doing then maybe when
you ask them the question what's the
most exciting project and why they give
one response or what's the most
challenging project of this year and why
was it challenging whereas if you were
in a different context you'd give a
different response because the
generative model of the system across
that interface is very different so the
response that it gives will be different
and it's going to be querying different
things and externalizing different
aspects of itself could be accurate
could be inaccurate
Scott so one of the things that raises
is I've been in some of the work that
I've done in cyber security I've been
parsing principles versus ethics versus
norms and so it's kind of interesting in
querying a group you're going to get an
average right you'll get a gaussian
distribution or whatever of opinion and
you'll then will it be informative um in
and so Norms I assert for these purposes
that their behaviors with uh behavioral
expectations that are set through the
past what was
normal and one of the assertions I make
is principles and again they're
assertions there's different overlap
here the principles are institutional
assertions of
aspiration and ethics also are
aspirational but they're human
assertions about human behaviors that's
the distinction I make whatever words
you want to use and so it's interesting
in the context of what you're talking
about about querying a group because
there's different evidentiary B group um
uh chunks that you'll look at right
normative you would be looking if if
according to those definitions on hey
what' we do before and what we do
against the set of standards that set
the principles may be more aspirational
and it may be you know how we doing
towards that thing but it's not
necessarily based on what was done
before you can you know you can say our
principles are more aspirational than
what we did before so it's interesting
just that interface of what's used in
the discussion of the group dynamics and
how that relates to what you were just
describing
which is the querying of the group and
individuals the framing of the nature of
that output you're getting from the
group is kind of interesting based on
that question asked right what do you do
before is one question what do you wish
to do in the future is a different
question yes so that query could be what
do you regularly do so again it could be
the person in the office and someone
says what is your morning routine that's
something we talked about in a previous
week or it could be a query to a team
what is your onboarding routine or how
do you welcome new members um and then
this question of the aspirational and
the Norms so it's funny because Norms
can mean what's normal it means what's
expected that's what has happened in the
past because what's not normal you know
if not if not the past what's normal but
at the same time normative means uh what
should be so a normative claim should be
like I think people should be treated
this way and that may or may not reflect
what has been the norm so people all of
uh belief systems make normative claims
that sometimes are consistent with norms
and sometimes are uh almost radically
Divergent from Norms someone says the
norm is a but I think the norm should be
B so I'm making a normative Claim about
the norms and it should be different and
so these are all interesting things to
uh yeah Scott so one big gap that's out
there in the world right now is the gap
between law and what and
interactions that technology allows and
I'm talking about fractally up and down
the chain reproductive interactions
biomedical population wide all these
different things the law is really
lagging okay so one of the things that's
interesting about this is there a
possibility that this kind of analysis
can help us to
discover
Norms that would
guide um uh groups and those Norms if
they're sufficiently interesting to the
groups can be made enforceable into laws
and so that to me this is a very
interesting way of of a possibility of
discovery of new laws and self-c
constraints that groups can put on
themselves in order to function as
larger systems in the globe kind of
context but I'll put that aside for now
but I just wanted to raise that is is
this a discovery is this a mechanism for
discovery of new working models of
larger scale norms
yes
Stephen yeah I think that that this is a
good point because and and discovering
that with this model here where you've
got this task specific and then you got
this effective actually as a as a larger
sort of scale time scale sort of
checking I think it's also relevant in
terms of how we can get mechanized in
our like if we just keep doing the same
task and we get the reward and the queue
and it starts to create a high sense of
this false sense of certainty in our
world which is so much about just
constructing more of our social Niche
and and alienating or externalizing the
environmental so we we can start to get
caught up in this kind of task specific
ways of working and silos and so that
maybe there's this this could speak to
why we need to do some sort of sense
breaking to sort of take us out of some
of these mechanizations and look at a
longer time scale um and use a effect to
do that integration and not just rely on
metrics cool let's let's take Scott's
point about this being not just an
enforcement understanding but a
discovery process and connect that to
some topics we've been considering like
bottom up versus top down function of
systems so the bottom up is learning
that's where the little ants are going
out and they're finding different things
or each of the cells in the retina is
receiving a different Photon each person
is receiving a different Newsfeed and
then as it goes quote up or in the
system it's being aggregated and that is
updating progressively more and more
summary like variables like of teams or
of organizations and then Norms can feed
back down to lower levels of the system
whether in the brain like the basing
brain or the predictive processing
hypothesis or whether it's team
communication Norms uh and those can be
informal or formal when we're talking
about human organizations we gain this
level of uh syntactic framing of top-
down priors so instead of just saying
this is how things are like uh the red
blood cells are flowing at this speed so
that's the speed they're flowing at
we're going to say there's a speed limit
and if you don't follow the speed limit
then we're going to have this type of
enforcement mechanism and so it could be
the case Cas that in the legal context
that if you just apply a law a top down
law it's kind of like trying to teach
someone a motor pattern uh let's just
say a speech law of some type of
controlling speech it's like controlling
someone's motor Behavior again because
it is a motor behavior and so what would
you do would you put them in the
exoskeleton and say okay here's a
perfect golf swing now you're a golfer
right well no you actually need to
practice and you need to have feedback
and so if the law is overly punitive and
it says oh that one time that you got
put in the exoskeleton you didn't
understand how to golf and other sports
that golfers know how could you not have
made the connection there from that one
time that I punished you for messing up
that is not an extremely helpful
framework for certain issues so how
could we have this biral conversation
where there's experimentation and
implementation at the edges and then
people's experience percolates up
upwards in the system and then the
system informally but eventually
formally ends up entrenching healthy or
productive or agreed upon patterns so
it's an interesting thought about how
these type of systems are uh not just
about learning they're not just about
exploitation as we've been thinking
about they're sort of in both domains
and they can trade off and when they
need to exploit they can dip into
exploitative uh type typ Behavior but
also they can be in an exploratory mode
Scott and it's also so much wrapped up
in identity it's amazing how this is a
new platform for identity because every
thing has a Markov blanket and it has
attributes and it external attributes
that are presented and so the discovery
when you have things like trade
associations markets communities of
Interest were things entities with
similar um I guess marov blankets and
attributes can cluster together forming
those systems which have larger scale
which enabled drisking and leverage for
the organism or organization at at at
larger levels so the discovery process
of bringing these markets are where
Markov blankets are um made
similar right because you go in and
there's a law it says if you're going
it's a flea market your table can only
be 5 by five so if you go in with a 7x5
table you can't go to that flea market
you have to follow the rules to be part
of the club but if you're in the club
you get the power of having more people
walking past your table to sell stuff so
there's the interface the law for the
vendor to the flea market and then
within that transaction there's a
subtransaction which is if you want this
little pocket knife you're going to give
me $3 and then I'll give you the pocket
knife so these are the nesting of
agreements in the context of identity
and forced and unenforced Norms blue and
then
Stephen so just to kind of tie into what
both you and Scott were saying so like
you know if we're ants and we're going
through the world like building this
generative model like as we discover as
we're learning right like so as we learn
we build the generative model like to
what extent is our generative model tied
into our identity like that's um It's
Curious to think about and and I mean I
know that like there's a policy update
and perhaps
the policy is more based on identity
like we talked about earlier like the
running every day uh maybe it's it's a
policy thing that's identity and so that
the we pick the the policy that that
then minimizes the free energy but but I
just wonder like you know the the
generative model how frequently that
that builds upon the identity like what
the relationship is between those two
okay and then
Stephen yeah well one thing that ties
into that question of identity and this
this type of model is and the mark of
blanket I suppose is how much
changes based on the D the the the
processing which could be um like this
um in the brain could be sort of
structured through the way the brain is
structured so there could be an
additional type of
structuring going on in which all of
this is able to work together and then
so how much is is this kind of um the
observations and the states in the sort
of brain computating in relation with
the body and how much is it just
literally the the way the mark of
blanket itself is changed you know so
and I think that's maybe an open
question at the moment because there's
the question I don't think as much as
the the idea of regimes of attention's
been talked about but literally how
would that change your computation by
bringing in different parts of the body
and the relation to the environment as
the sort of Mark of blanket to integrate
information coming in and how much is
through computation and I sense that
a that at certain times maybe when
you're learning something for the first
time it's very computationally heavy but
then as you draw things down and it
becomes kind of tacit knowledge we might
become subconsciously able to flow and
shift yes formal systems can become
integrated through muscle memory so
somebody who's learning how to play
violin they don't need to know the math
of the frequency overlap they might
learn that in their Journey but also it
becomes Incorporated through culturally
acquired practices and muscle memory and
that could be carried out into other
areas
Scott there was an article uh just read
recently in nature or science which
relates to the the um Steph's last point
and it was about how in in cultures
where there were Deaf culture so there
isolated populations I think there was
one in Central America there was one in
the Middle East of deaf people because
it was some kind of genetic thing and so
large populations of isolated people who
were deaf and what they found is when
they came up with their independent sign
languages they were all independently
generated what they found in this
research is they used the body in each
of the isolated populations the body was
used in the same way different parts
like first I'm going to make up the
parts because I can't remember them but
they would first use the face parts then
they would use the left arm then they
would use the right arm then they would
use the core of the body the morphology
of speech through sign language was
identical across the human populations
even though they were isolated from each
other in terms of what they added on I
forget what it was with the bigger
Concepts or the the things that were
emotional there were different
morphologies of that sit I guess
situating their expression in their
morphology in other parts of their
morphology so I thought it would relate
to that I'm not sure how but it feels
like that form of expression being
uniform across humans it's like the um
theories of humans having a language
capacity I forget who who's that is
maybe mclan or somebody anyway but it's
it's interesting that the morphology of
the
body sounds like there's some intrinsic
um uh tearing of what Express ression
comes through what parts of the
body I'll try to find the arle very
interesting and that actually reminds me
of William Blake's poetry and the
four-fold albon which is a metaphor for
Cosmic Persona as well as all of England
as well as the individual body and so
it's a metaphor that he returns to many
times in an allegorical context and it's
so evocative because it speaks to a
multiscale system and it is of
applying to multi multiscale systems
Stephen yeah thanks for that uh Scott
because I think that's I mean that could
actually also you know there's all this
thing about this innate language
capacity which has now been kind of
discounted but I mean if actions first
and the morphology is maybe more related
certainly within certain you know
environmental niches that people have
grown up in um that would maybe explain
why there was that confusion in the
language world because people s of Saw
language Universal well actually if the
morphologies where it's at and language
is just an another type of morphology
that's kind of building on the core
morphology of the body that's where that
pattering was coming from not the
language itself or the language in
process look and I was just going to say
extending that out further one of the
assertions that I've started to make and
and believe is that the mind doesn't
reside in the brain at all the Mind
resides in language and in material
culture and the brain is an antenna that
we tune into the local mind wherever
where we're exposed to that's why
colonialists put indigenous populations
children in their
schools right they take they want to
tune their mind into a colonialist
culture early because they then renders
the externality innocuous for their
colonialism anyway yes that's true of
all children's education uh including
cont temporary and to bring in this key
point of precision um again active
inference is not about systems finding
the most rewarding State and then
sticking with it it's about Precision so
to connect that to Identity um the
child's education is being uh it's
basically being given symbols that will
help it navigate the regularities in its
Niche and again there can be
dysfunctional education that leads to
children that are incapable of taking
advantage or of working with the
regularities in the niche but this is
where the policy selection piece comes
into play to kind of return it to the
figure because that's like important to
return to what the paper said is the
policy selection piece is so tied up
with identity it's not that there's an
identity like who we are and then
there's this totally separate question
of what we do it actually is we are how
we act and to even take it to another
level the understanding of how the world
changes s the states that are external
that we care about the understanding of
how those States change is related to
the policy actions that the system takes
and so that even brings this relational
mode another level deeper it's not just
like saier War oh well the words that
you use change how you think or they
influence how you think it's everything
is influential on how we think because
how we think is like this emergent
outcome from all those factors so it's a
starting point to say that the words
that we have or the affordances or the
sensory capacities that we have shape
our understanding of the niche that's
the starting point
blue so just to piggyback on the idea of
a team and identity like like how and
also where the mind is like where is the
mind of a team right like when you're
when you're thinking about this in terms
of active inference and so the the
individual team members I mean we've all
worked on teams before at at various
points and it's amazing how the team
changes based on the like the function
of its individual components right like
so there there are different people that
bring different Dynamics to a team some
people may be louder stronger or less
influential or or everyone has their
different kind of role in a team and and
these all like really bring changes to
the overall structure and the way that
the team will react right like like
based on a query like when you query a
team you know what is the best project
of the Year that'll change based on the
the individual components of that team
yep and the team organism mapping let's
think about team onboarding and the way
that the interface of the organism is
like an interface of a team so the
immune system of a person there's times
where something is onboarded but in a
very controlled way and it does not
trigger the immune system so for example
if you eat something in the stomach
which is a specialized chamber that
digests food it is then absorbed through
the interface of the gut in a
controllable way in a way where only the
safe pieces like you know that sugars
are coming in and the amino acids are
coming in lipids are coming in so
through that controlled and
evolutionarily selected upon interface
there is an onboarding process that's
healthy but if there's a onboarding
event on your body like a cut in your
skin it's going to trigger the immune
system so that's more like a security
breach for a team whereas eating for a
team might be like hey we're going to
get this ingest of new data our
colleague is going to send us a data set
it's going to come from this email
address and it's this type if it's from
a different email address I'm not going
to see it or if it's of a different type
we're going to need to change our
pipeline but if it's this type of food
coming at this interface and it's you
know this structure we're going to be
able to digest that and then use the
information latent in that input to help
our team become more structured or to
expand just like an organism would break
down the food and uh use it to grow
itself or to operate
Stephen and also with team you've got
the the teleology of the team like the
purpose the goals and I think that that
I mean this figure sort of speaking a
lot to task based you know ways of of
things being evaluated with rewards and
the way that we structure our teams
often with the way that we then
construct the environment to sort of
lead us towards those rewards in a way
and I'm really interested I've been
looking at this thing called infusion
space that I've been working working on
is when we are in a kind of an organized
space with a teleology and and a
direction like a team and organization
and then when we're in a sort of
community uh space where which maybe
this isn't I think it's another process
of affect where we're sort of attuning
to um that kind of inter subjective
dynamic between us and you know there's
there's one's more efficient the team's
more efficient if your goal is the right
goal the danger is that you could be
they talk about now with the modern
world is we're getting very good at
doing the wrong things so it can be the
Trap you fall into so climate change
being a classic case we're very good
doing things we shouldn't be doing um so
I think there's an interesting question
there about a teleological Dynamic
aligned to goals and rewards which
everything's then and could actually
remove the The Knowing of your affect
and you can just ignore it because
you're getting other kicks and when the
deeper knowing is like you know it's not
really going to be good when you talk
about really long time
scales okay let's expand on that so
thology is coming from the word Tios
which is the end so tileology is the
study in philosophy of what systems are
as defined by their ends so the purpose
of something like houses are to keep
people warm and what are people for but
instead of engaging in the philosophy of
heliology like what is it mean to be a
human what are we here for we can think
about it from a cybernetics perspective
which is also equivalent to like an
intentional stance in philosophy and
that's kind of like saying like Okay
look whether or not we're ever going to
figure out the ultimate Tios of a human
or the ultimate Tios of our team at the
very least as a goal-seeking system that
has to operate amidst uncertainty and
communicate through limited and noisy
channels we need to have Clarity on our
mission our local
Tios so that we can have Clarity on
action and again if your local mission
is something that is uh pursuable then
it's it's a second layer whether it's
quote good or bad and that's the whole
question about what Scott raised with
the marov blankets of uh legal entities
and there it's kind of easy to see some
of the analogies between let's say a
society and a person if each cell were
to fight for its marov blanket then
things could get hairy pretty pretty
fast whereas over evolutionary time the
interfaces between cells of the organism
have evolved through so many different
proteins and so many different
mechanisms to work well together to be
compatible within the organism and
similarly within a healthy operating
system for legal entities you could
imagine there would be healthy
interfaces but in the absence of a
healthy interface then even entities
whose interests are completely aligned
might end up in extremely adversarial
context Together
Scott and I think that might be the
problem with kant's Emanuel kant's uh
what is it called the something
imperative categorical imperative yes
and is that the notion that if the a
human acts a good in human acts in a
good way it'll be good for
society so uh the the contient
imperative as it's uh called a
categorical imperative sometimes uh it's
uh I'm just just wanted to look up an
exact word it is quoted as a rule of
conduct that is unconditional or
absolute for all agents the validity of
claim of which does not depend on any
desire or end that yeah that reads
heavily as that classic era of
abstraction in philosophy and that's one
of the problems in European law right
now and identity law like gdpr and those
kind of things in the real world their
idea of entities and of identity is
based on Hegel and kantt
and those are there there is a real
focus on that individual being good and
that being enough to have the entire
Society work well and I think that's
part of the pro challenges over there
that that in Continental law you make
the law um and you refer back to the
statute all the time in common law which
is any place that was part of the
British Empire you what you do is you
come up with a half-ass version of the
law and then you allow common law to fix
it up so the common law acts as a
continually Dynamic
revisiting um because the courts then
make the law and then when you when you
have a later case you don't just look at
the original statute you look at the
cases as well the other court cases and
so it's been modified by that so one of
the things that this gets Tangled Up In
is
philosophically the question of how much
of a teleology you have I believe my
personal belief is that because they had
royalty a tradition of royalty on the
European continent that they're more
amenable to a single voice
and so that single voice can act in a
misdirected way for a longer period of
time because it projects onto a paradigm
onto the population but it's just
something that it's it gets softer at
that level perhaps because we don't have
the data and the metrics but it feels
like those same kind of things are
iterating from a system perspective if
you have something that's too stuck in
the mud it's not going to change as fast
and now that's happening everywhere
since technology mors law increases
interactions exponentially all of our
institutions all of them were intended
to drisk and leverage much more
leisurely institutional context so
they're no longer fit for function in
the interaction Landscapes we have and
so one of the questions is does how in
what way might this analysis help us to
not just improve old institutions that
might not be possible but construct
institutions that can better be dynamic
with the increased frequency and volume
of interactions we have which is
perceived by any one institution as an
increase in density interaction density
that's why your calendar is all jammed
up because we're still using calendars
the way we used to use them which is
linear progression of things they have
to do things like that so anyway sorry
about the question there yeah
interesting
Stephen well that might that also might
tie into this idea of when we have
systems in our Niche that we've created
when you know when do we need them to be
more able to our own active inference
types of Dynamics like if we if this is
the type of way that we can you know
what would help us being better at
attuning and what types of attention
what types of scale would we want this
kind of dynamical process and when does
it want to be fixed and it kind of
speaks another problem in the
development world was the rights based
approach to development so someone
somewhere defines what people's rights
are and what's and then it gets dictated
down but that causes a lot of problems
when you roll out into cultures which
value things slightly different to those
that decided what's right and it's also
what's right for someone in a poor
context or a poverty context might not
be quite is with someone in a in a in a
developed wealthy context so the same
you know maybe this is a question that
needs to be asked is when do we need to
have this kind of active influence or
godic help you know thought about create
and when do we say look this isn't being
done that way we're just going to Bol it
down and use a non-ergodic kind of
structured state of this sort of laws
okay interesting so let's try to connect
that to uh cont and then back to action
because that's the key piece and that's
what we really want to emphasize with
the active inference approach is that
although we generalize we're
generalizing to reduce our uncertainty
about observations which could be
letters or sounds we're hearing we're
reducing our uncertainty about the
stimuli that we're as people receiving
by generalizing so that we can guide
action and so the categorical imperative
on Wikipedia it says it's best known
from its first formulation Act only
according to that Maxim whereby you can
at the same time will that it should
become a universal law so that's
actually also related in a sense like a
symmetry relationship with the Rian
theories of Justice like what would be
fair would be if you were to be a random
draw you'd want to be in that Society
versus another Society but here's where
active inference and action and the
reality of the finite world come into
play different people have different
risk preference trade-offs so maybe
somebody says yeah I'll take a one in a
million chance of being the dictator and
somebody else says no I'd rather have an
100% chance of being in this other world
where everyone has the exact same amount
of official power for example but even
at a deeper level that's a thought
discussion and it's becoming
increasingly lifted from action and from
policy selections that we as the agents
perceiving that question are being faced
with and so when people bring in the
things like it should become a universal
law that's a normative Claim about a
universalism about a law you know and
who's the judge jury executioner so
although the sentence the imperative
started with act according to dot dot do
dot dot it ended up in the clouds with
some speculation about what could or
would or should become Universal and
ostensibly enforced by other people with
weapons but not yourself so how do we
tie it back to the real system and
confront oursel with what we actually
are being faced with from an affordance
and from a challenges perspective and
then ask what policies will help guide
the whole system towards states that we
want to see but at first we can just
acquire Precision about who are we what
are our relationships what are our
interfaces how can we think in a more
rigorous multiscale way about how we are
composed of our relationships so not
that I'm some Adam and I'm being
influenced by my relationships but it's
multiscale relationships all the way up
and down so what is really happening
here these are some interesting ways
that sidestep morality when working
together but they sidestep the ways that
morality has been framed in terms of
well I think it should become a
universal law that I should get all the
money and then it's easy for me to act
within the categorical imperative under
that understanding and someone says well
no that's not the real understanding and
then you're right back to square zero so
how are we going to use systems thinking
but also include aspects of
Intercultural communication and
understanding that people are going to
be having different experiences of the
same deal the same interface different
people are going to have different
experiences of it and then work within
that environment so that's kind of you
know some big areas that hopefully we'll
be thinking about in the coming years
because there are uh serious questions
about how to interface formal systems
with people Scott one of the things
that's interesting right now in law is
that you know it's really showing wear
and tear and people are really focusing
on liability and rights and things like
that which is terrific but one of the
things the right is an is an
expectation and what the law does is it
constructs a bunch of Duties around that
right that give life to the right so if
I say I have a right to free speech and
nobody has a duty to respect it then I
don't have anything except words on
paper and so the duties the construction
of Duties what that does is it's
constraint on other uh expression other
Marco of blankets right you're limiting
and constraining the environment of
other individuals you'll meet because
they have a duty to do x a duty to
there's a a judge who said years ago in
in United States your right to swing
your head arm in public ends where my
nose
begins right so you can keep doing this
until my nose is next to where you're
swinging your arm so it's interesting
isn't it that you have this that is
really that Dynamic element if a nose is
introduced into that system you got to
stop swinging your arm right and so the
anticipation of situations where you
shouldn't swing your arm don't swing
your arm in an elevator you know that
kind of thing right don't don't spit on
the subway right you start to have these
rules which are like hey we can
generalize that duty to a population and
if it's relatively innocuous like red
means
stop purple could mean stop it's not the
light that stops the car it's the
behavior elicited by the signal so there
are a lot of innocuous things we can
avoid avoidable harms by agreeing on
innocuous signaling for certain duties
and behaviors that would render those
rights to be realized and to be live
living yep so with this kind of eating
team metaphor ingestion of stimuli or of
food at the organism level and that's
being processed either chemically with
the food or informationally with the
stimuli in order to guide action so we
can think about these teams and
organizations as getting inputs and then
engaging in action in their Niche and
the goal of the inputs and selection is
going to shape this is so that the
inputs can be processed in a way that
leads to outputs that are effective and
so again another mapping would be to a
heat system so like an engine if you can
convert 100% of the potential energy
into work it's a very efficient system
and it doesn't lose a lot to heat
whereas if you have a system that's
broken or has inefficiencies in it it
will perform very little work in its
task specific uh role and it will
release a lot as heat which is like
wasted energy that's like data exhaust
there's wasted data there's so many
mappings here actually in the last
couple minutes let's just run through
the slides see if anything comes to mind
but other than that I'm sure we could
keep on you know thinking about this
figure two of the paper the authors
showed this roll out game and uh the
agent at each time point is imagining
what could happen on future timelines
and so here's a timeline where I stay in
this neutral State on the left side
here's a timeline where I get to state
three and that's good and then I go to
state four and it's bad and so as you
simulate and you roll out more and more
and more deeply that's the sophisticated
or the Deep component as you roll that
out in order to track what uh kind of a
world you're in are you in a world where
all the routes are bad or all them are
good or some are good and some are bad
the agent is tracking a few things it's
tracking the state estimates like the
expected value of different policy
choices but also the variance or the
uncertainty and what we saw in this
paper was that as the agent starts
initially thinking and simulating deeply
it starts to be perceiving it self in
states that are rewarding and it has
relatively High Precision about being
able to maintain itself in those States
but as it continues to simulate deeper
and deeper the Precision of its model
drops this is associated with anxiety
from the computational Psychiatry
perspective and uh it's also associated
with the increased percentage of the
events being negative but not a 10x
increase in the events being negative
and as we pointed out last time it's
actually when the threat perception is
at a medium level when the anxiety
skyrockets and again this specific Trace
is just related to the parameters of
this model so it's not meant to be a
general Claim about anxiety or something
like that it is for future work to
really map this onto Real World
Systems we had the formalisms which
people can pause and look at um the
formalisms of sophisticated inference
and the uh real natural language
translations of some of these variables
that are interacting in these
papers we talked about the generalized
free energy and about how that formalism
has a few different parts one of those
parts is conditioned on policies and it
talks about the relational mapping
between observations and states and then
the other function here is conditioned
on policy and it's uh
yeah sorry let me just rephrase that one
of these sides is conditioned on policy
and relates to States the other side is
conditioned on observations and states
and it relates to policy
selection um we talked about a few other
topics intrinsic and external value
General and special cases and uh how
when you are moving through a prediction
in this branching way there's an
exponentially increasing number of
states and so in order to deal with that
organisms or systems have to engage in a
little bit more of a guided kind of
search and that brings us to this slide
which is what I kind of wanted to pause
on because I think blue this is what
made you say we have to invite Scott so
what what was interesting to you here
what made you think of
that just uh Scott and how um Scott's
always presenting on risk and this just
was like well I think that Scott really
needs to be here and based on also the
fact that Scott um said he'd been
studying active inference since the
October complexity weekend so those two
things kind of
nailed it for me it's I feel like it's a
it's this giant thing smorgus board
that's in the Next Room that I haven't
yet entered into that's it's it's so
delightful I'm so thrilled by my
ignorance in this this is the best gift
I could ever get so thank you all you
know it's like a roomto room party you
just go room to room and it's always a
new setting but we're bringing the party
along because it's enacted it's not that
there's a room of researchers or a
community that's waiting for us to be on
boarded onto we're we're co-
domesticating each other and creating
the community that we want to see so
that's self-organization and multiscale
organization in action and we can think
about that actually tying it back to
this figure so the active inference
framework under special cases which were
described in this
slide we can think about a few different
cases where certain things are driven to
zero so when there's no uncertainty
about States in other words states of
the world can be perfectly known then
risk sensitive policies can be
enacted so um when there's no ambiguity
about States you can talk about risk
that's this part right here however when
there is ambiguity about states you have
to reduce that uncertainty and that's
sort of like if you don't know what the
states of the system are
you you can't operate but to the extent
you have reduced ambiguity about the
observations in States you're able to
increasingly plan risk sensitive policy
so Scott that makes me think about in a
world of digital transactions where we
can have reduced uncertainty about
certain types of events happening could
we then move some of that energy and
focus to risk aware policy so that's one
piece here that's why I call what we
have right now is self boiling
nice so that's the that's the saddle
meme this is still within the context of
how most people think about ambiguity
and uncertainty
vuka that's in the terms of minimization
of two different things minimize
uncertainty minimize risk first go ahead
and reduce your uncertainty about the
states and then to whatever extent you
can do that reduce our uncertainty about
the future Vis A reducing risk that's
the normal framework for most people or
at least it's one way to think about it
but now let's think about it um active
inference not just in a risk control way
but in this basy and statistical
framework a variational framework where
we're actually doing not just a double
minimization but we're doing like a push
pull with a minimization and an
exploration simultaneously so we're
going to be able to dynamically adjust
explore exploit it's not exactly explore
exploit as we talked about but it's like
explore exploit because we can
dynamically adjust the relative pressure
waiting of the in and the out so we're
always exploring and we're also always
reducing our
uncertainty about the system and so
that's why the uh two arrows are moved
into an
overlapping uh area just graphically
this is just a loose graphical model
here because not it's not a disjoint
two-step process ambiguity about States
and then ambiguity about risk if we have
certainty about States this is the co-
joint estimation
of all these pieces together in a way
that's a push pull so there's a couple
Paradigm changing ways of framing risk
and operating in this uh mode and that
will it'll lead to different types of
institutional structures that'll be
distributed which will resemble
neighborhood watch but it won't just be
neighborhood watch it'll be neighborhood
creation as well that's a fundamental
change exactly instead of just putting
up the law at like a trip wire and then
triggering it you could say how do we
just have people who are going on a
neighborhood walk just people walking
the neighborhood it's like you know like
they could just having fun and being
social could that be the actual thing
and so it fuses several of the previous
ways of thinking about it well we're
going to reduce our uncertainty about
what's happening in the neighborhood and
then we're going to do a risk
minimization policy well this makes you
think about installing surveillance
cameras but what if you said we're going
to jointly be discovering what community
Norms we have and what we want to be
aspirationally as a neighborhood Hood
around safety or around communication
and maybe there's a way where we can
just go on walks in the afternoon and
all of a sudden people are connecting
and it's a safer world and the other
just one other thing I I once read an
article about the world champion fly tie
tire and he tied flies and they were the
be most successful flies for catching
fish but all the people complain that
his flies didn't look like actual
insects they didn't fool humans and he
said I don't have to fool the humans I
just have to fool the
fish and so the reason I say that here
is the way we're going to do this is
we're going to use a left side we're
going to get people in by saying hey you
got risk what you been doing about the
risk let's talk about the risk okay
that's fine we're going to get other
people in the room who are going to be
talking about the same risk but they
people never met each other before and
then by the time they leave the room
they're going to be in the right hand
side of the design that's where the
governance is going to shift we're going
to hook them with something they res
they recognize like The Fish Guy we're
going to hook him with the thing on the
left which is hey r we're going to talk
about risk that's with the atlas of risk
I'll send it around to the other folks
but some of you have it it's 870
different information risks that are
shared by people now because digital
stuff has made everybody have trouble so
they they come for the the risks they
know but by the time they leave they're
going to be organized into different
groups that aren't going to be dealing
with the risk the risk was just the
existing risk description was just a way
to get them in the
room yes yes so one metaphor before
Stephen instead of let's let's measure
your blood measure your blood measure
your blood so that we can measure your
risk of the disease this is like how
could we be doing active inference on
health and working towards Health in a
way that yeah maybe we'll do a
measurement here or there and we do want
to reduce risk and we will reduce risk
but we're actually framing it in a way
that's like a journey related to health
in mind rather than ambiguity risk
disease negative negative negative
uncertainty anxiety how about
yin and yang with a little bit of a more
balanced understanding about how we can
function and enact policy
Stephen this is a very important diagram
actually like you're saying this this
takes us away from just trying to reduce
uncertainty about the external stimuli
and the kind of locked in risk aversion
and you're actually working more with
that time dependent or time series um
approach that active influence gives of
like well how are things changing and
how just like that fish looking at the
the fly how does that um embodied agent
and the wisdom and recognizing that
there's a wisdom about how to be in the
world and how to be with your Niche how
is that actually being used to inform
how we make things happen and not just
this more mechanical
approach yes and good points there
um in active inference stream 19 Yonder
in mid April uh we're going to have
deeply felt affect which is one of the
papers that was cited in this paper but
we're going to go into it in more detail
we'll talk about perception about
anticipation
action metacognition implicit metac
cognition and just to close out I listed
a few questions um do people want to
hang out for a few more minutes and talk
for uh a little bit yeah sounds good but
I'll just give the closing slide and
then we'll return to the question slide
thanks everyone for participating the
live viewers uh have a link to a
feedback form in the event everyone else
really thanks so much for 2020 super
special and unique experience for all of
us so really deeply appreciated for
those watching live or in replay or
whenever wherever it was great times so
thanks a lot and we're just getting
started so
for a little bit longer whoever wants to
stay and if you want to leave just just
no worries just drop off but um what's
something that somebody wants to go into
here or what's something that still
people want to bring
up one of the one of the things I'm
wondering about is just the we've been
taking this from a single individual
perspective to some extent and in those
group perspec Ive is kind of it's
interesting that the simultaneity of all
of it that the you you know you
simultaneously have an individ it's this
the how do how do we get a handle how do
we help people get a handle on the the
many levels that operate
simultaneously and
then one of the then then how do we
bring that to the current time the now
where everyone is acting in this moment
I you know reading another paper now on
fractal time and they say hey the past
and the future don't exist if they do
where are they show me right so the idea
is now is all that exists so we have
these priors which were that and we have
these future projections which are that
but we have the now and we all act in
the now and all these
Myriad Dynamics feed into the
now and so it's such an interesting
notion to me of how to trim tab systems
as a lawyer you don't just we don't just
observe we're always trying to push
things in One Direction or another for
clients right or for whatever and so it
feels like it's such an interesting
thing that we have it's not just a now
we have a series of Nows available to us
I guess because we in the diagram you
see a series of Nows right in the in the
steps
so it's interesting to that temporal
aspect is something that's just
not brought into so many systems right
they're so static in so many ways and so
in a sense like when you working with
standards people they'll say oh it has
to be robust so that we can plan based
on it but it also has ref flexible and
it feels like this naturally this
analysis naturally lends itself once it
becomes an institutionalized thing
because our institutions now are not
built on these analyses but once they're
built on the Dynamics they're built on
I'll use the word uncertainty but it's
really embracing uncertainty or as I
said in 2014 you called it entropy
engines we were actually mining disorder
in order to create
order so anyway just a couple of things
that thoughts that came to mind it feels
like that time issue is relevant to our
understanding how we can mind
disorder cool
Stephen yeah the time issues definitely
a big part and we see that with these
papers we' seen that there's the
narrative approaches there the
reflective and now they're trying to get
into the pre-reflective more and
traditionally that's been you know
meditation but what is the way that we
understand these different time scales
and I what I'd be interested in is is is
how does this link in with affordances I
think there's something really
interesting about that Niche and the
affordances in a niche because it it
gives
away because it's sort of permanent
before you know like that the path could
still be there the cups can still be
there you yet my interaction with it can
vary so I think that that's a a really
interesting um way that experiments can
tie a lot of this information or
knowledge together sure so one idea
we've talked a lot about is the idea of
attracting sets or attracting States so
for the perspective of your body with
regards to temperature you want to be
attracting back to core body temperature
excursions outside of that range are not
just bad they lethal so attracting
states are really important and just
like you can have attracting sets of
States on a single number line like
temperature you can have in the
wandering itinerant dynamics of thought
you can have attracting thoughts and you
can ruminate and you can get too
attracted or it can be too precise but
it's an idea that people could be
familiar with or not that attracting
States can be thoughts so let's think
about active inference the framework as
an attracting State as something where
we can in a room bring up these ideas
and refocus the discussion or
potentially expand or uh zoom in so
we've brought up this multiscale and the
Deep past and the Deep future so there
multiscale through space like the nested
systems and then there's multiscale
through time there's molecules vibrating
and then there's longer term things so
let's start with the multiscale space
and time just being our starting
position and then active inference goes
further it says not just is it going to
start being multiscale in space and time
but there's going to be nonlinearity and
uncertainty because there are causes in
the world so RJ and his alarm clock and
his dog and something that you wouldn't
expect changed in the world and that
changed another part of the world that
you basically wouldn't have expected um
and also our action is always going to
be constrained by our situational
affordances in the niche so to Steven's
Point there which is like it's all good
to think about objectively what's
happening but constrained by affordances
in the niche that we're actually in is
the operating conditions we have so it
makes sense to at least ground the
discussion in the affordances and then
we're presented with attracting set of
questions like how will we work together
to be agents in a system of the type we
would like to
see that's a question that in various
settings people could say oh well we
don't have Clarity on what kind of
system we want to be in we need to
reduce our uncertainty about what kind
of system we're in that's visioning and
clarifying Mission but then there's
other times where people say yeah how do
we be the Agents of this kind of a
system that we want to be in so we're
not uncertain about the mission about
the end cybernetically but I'm just like
honestly confused about what next role I
should take in this system to make this
happen according to this mission that
we've laid out and if my actions are
consistent with the mission as we've
laid it out then they're good but if
they're not then they're just not
helpful so we can start to combine a lot
of these ideas and realize hopefully
that whether we go deep into the physics
side or into another aspect of active
inference we'll use it as an attracting
set and as this range in Phase space
where we can bring the discussion and
help ground it in the multiscale
insights in the nonlinearity of the
world and a few other
things but I think it's yeah and they
really are they really are that
like we we start our diagram with
entities that have
priors right we're not starting with I
mean you could start with no priors and
you're just wandering around in the dark
in the woods but we're starting within
system that has something that we
comparing the reality to right so
they're trying to minimize the
difference between their expectation in
reality is that the free energy notion
right so um so sculpting expectations at
the front end is what education is an
experience right and so with you know
when we can you know our our system is
our educational system in the United
States is set up for after the based on
the Prussian school system right that's
the um D the deschooling society book by
um illich um so we're our expectation is
industrial workers well now we don't
have industrial workers only we have
service workers and so our educational
system is not serving our folks for
instance right so we have these um th
those influences it's the I guess the
the thing that's the thing I keep coming
back to it's like a situated
cognition that we situate our cognition
in externalities well those
externalities also have are entities
that have Markoff blankets you know
right now we're thinking together right
this is like Plato you said you know
dialogue lets us query Consciousness so
we're doing that um and each of us has
our own view on on the direction of this
thing right but they're so we're not
interacting with static things we're
interacting with Dynamic things that
have their own Dynamics and the
recruitment of those
populations is I think a lot of what
happens in legal Concepts it's what's
it's what right now I think this this
the things we're doing right now could
make a big impact on ethics
discussions because ethics anything
that's not written down in law but is
bad is now called an ethical problem
right it's just ethics is carrying a lot
of water right now for anxieties of
people generally with the Technologies
and exponential increase in everything
so it feels like we have an opportunity
for
intervention because there is a
vacuum um of meaning in the current
institutions and it feels like this kind
of explanation might be a nice way to
get a Toe Hold there let me build on
that Scott so there was a book um I read
called Legal systems very different from
our own by a fellow with the last name
of fredman but it is not myself or
relative directly and it really does a
great job of capturing how different
legal systems from uh informal like
criminal or prison legal systems Justice
systems using the term quite broadly to
different world traditions very very
different processes that they followed
but also they had different ends in mind
now the current operating environment
not just are we being confronted with
different uh interfaces mixing that
hadn't combined before but also there's
new challenges and so that's sort of
like there was a you know a two-stroke
engine and a two-stroke engine and a
two-stroke engine and they all were kind
of coupled in a way where they all were
working internally and now they're being
cobbled together and there's a lot of
heat informationally so to speak there's
a lot of parts that can burn because
there's so much heat being wasted with
the interfaces and so can three
two-stroke engines be simply rewired
into a six-stroke engine well no it
doesn't really work that way how can you
link those engines together into a
system and that's really the question
we're we're um addressing here is
narratively linguistically mimetically
but just formally as well how will these
different systems get C together so that
we're actually connecting the gasoline
to the car moving in forward One
Direction and in one piece not taking
gasoline and making something that's
just combustible but only hurting people
Yep this is this is where I suggested
people read
flatland because it's the adding of
Dimensions right you add Mr sphere comes
in and lifts Mr square up and he can see
through you can untie a knot in the
upper Dimension without crossing the
knot the Rope right so in law what we do
is you create a new dimension so there
was a time when we didn't have credit
cards and people used to do run IUS at
the bar and things like that it just
didn't exist and so credit cards now
serve this huge function they drisk huge
sads of interactions right but at one
point they just didn't exist and this
guy de Hawk wrote a book called the
birth of the chaotic age and it's kind
of a crappy book but it's kind of an
interesting notion the banks were like
no no no no no we don't want your credit
cards go away get out of here was a
paradigm shift and then eventually they
got the credit cards got in and now try
taking the credit card fees away from
the banks right so what was impossible
becomes inevitable and it feels like
because things are so
stuck this kind of approach that we're
talking about when taken in markets and
institutions is going to that extra
dimension of credit cards or swaps frees
up it allows for these interactions to
take place just like the extra dimension
in flatland allowed for Mr Square to get
New Perspectives on his life and his
existence so it's it's a really it's a
fundamentally different and that's why
they it's so interesting the Markov
blanket
nesting gets really interesting what
which Marco blanket can Nest within
another one and when you have community
of Interest one of the things I always
remind people of in in New York for
instance you have Little Italy you have
a Chinatown you have different areas
where people go together because their
markof blankets their language is easier
it's easier to communicate lowers the
cost of communication lowers the risk
you also have the jewelry district the
the Flower District and the U cookware
District economically people cluster
together so communities of Interest
they're collocating well here if we look
at your diagram with the four states you
know the two states on the left two
states on right every one is now accumul
they're going to communities of Interest
based on the Dynamics or rigidity of
that left-and two states you know oh do
you share a risk do you share a solution
but what if we could have communities of
Interest accumulated based on their
capacity for change instead or something
like that just to raise one really
important piece then Stephen is when
people align around on the left side of
that figure reducing risk or shared
policy or shared culture it's often a
similarity clustering okay so people
often cluster based upon similar needs
similar understanding of the world
similar affordances but let's imagine um
the reality of the organism which is
that actually it's a clustering on the
opposite in some senses of disjoint
abilities so in this context of the body
if you said well there's one kind of
cell it can't move it just holds a bunch
of fat and it it literally just does
hormone and fat processing and there's
another kind of cell that will just dry
out in second in the Sun but it can
contract once and there's this other
kind of and it's like you'd say they're
not going to live in the same
neighborhood together it's like oh wait
no they do that's the body and so how
are we going to interpret this all the
levels of what it means to be a person
economically and culturally and
psychologically and understand that it's
neither simple Affinity nor simple
disaffinity on any scale that will lead
to function because function and the
islands of function are rare in the
almost unimaginably large State space of
possible legal codexes or possible
programmingsoftware
system it's not a simple imperative but
at the largest level that accomplishes
our mission so just such interesting
topics
Stephen yeah and this well just like you
were just saying there about these
different cultures and the niche
construction I think this can help
there's a lot of problems in terms of
discourse around this not more broadly
in the world and I've like when we talk
about systems out there in like City but
then well how much is a system how much
has been an
evolving Niche construction some of
which is constructed in this kind of
linear you know this kind of
teleological strategic way from above
and and and geographical way and um but
also some of it's just because that's
the way it's evolved over time with some
of this like we say these Dynamics I
think haven't really been brought in or
if they are brought in they kind of ends
up in the s and it it all gets framed in
whichever metaphor a particular sort of
school is applying and that you can get
trapped by that and and I think this
this actually came up for me today so
just like you talking about the
indigenous um ways you could have of
governance or other ways is I think that
we we have this idea of systems and
these different systems and how do we
integrate them and this this assumption
that they we need to be integrating them
but like the these indigenous systems
you know it flips from one to the other
so for instance we have our Western
system which seems to be like and we
need to attack our system is quite a
sort of a progressive leftist approach
or we need to all revert to some sort of
native indigenous system and they had it
right and the body knows everything and
if we just listen to our body and
there's this kind
of Gap whereby how do you find a way
which is kind of maybe configuring
different approaches so it's like okay
well where can we
configure the other ways of knowing
other ways of governing other ways of
and it's not just a case of like mash
them together because they may just have
a completely different
dynamical process and then they don't
integrate they just do different things
at different times like cells do in the
body of course it's all going to come
down to the details so you know none of
these metaphors or um you know
questions are even the beginnings of the
answer but yes that's definitely where
we want to be understanding at that the
level of societies is how much formal
integration will there be now if
somebody says I have I designed the
interface for different operations that
is still coming from a cultural context
so the challenge and part of the quest
will be to frame that interface in a way
that doesn't pretend that it has the
neutral Arbiter ability cuz that's
actually one of those Universalist
fallacies that were fallen into by
abstractionists now we want to be
grounded in action and still talk about
an interface for action and so I think
actually that's why the task may be
easier than the thought bringing
together could be the action bringing
together I'm always reminded of Scott's
example that he told me a long time ago
with two lumber yards that are competing
in the market for selling Lumber but
then they have the same insurance and
then I like wait they also could have
the same internet provider and they
could pay taxes to the same local
government and they could have the same
lunch service it's like everything
except for lumber so it's like how many
fronts they might even share a fence
they so many areas so they're almost
collaborative on more fronts than not
and so how do we take this understanding
that on overwhelming number of our edges
and even for each Edge on most of the
domains there's just massive areas where
we're in alignment and then risk can be
catastrophic so it's like if we just
reduce the amount of cascading failures
in the
system by playing to our strengths in
the areas where we are aligned maybe all
of a sudden now the lumber yard people
it's like oh you like this kind of wood
I like this kind of wood we should just
Niche partition but we're not going to
go Niche partition and fork and never
talk if you're going to be selling the
luxury and I'm going to be selling the
consumer wood we need to have a better
communication interface oh you have
employees who speak this language and I
have employees who speak this language
well let's make an agreement that we're
going to send numbers back and forth in
this file type on these dates and here's
who we're going to go to if that doesn't
work it's like wow these two companies
were fighting on the market in a
previous or a different Paradigm they
might have you know been wasting money
on advertising or committing different
sort of Gray Zone interferences with
each other's operation but just by
reframing it in this multiscale system
even if you're not doing a government
change whatever government system there
is those two lumber yards now have a new
way of talking to each other to their
employees with their lawyers whatever
potentially in a way that could lead
towards them working together better so
that's just very powerful I think that's
what it will be cool to continue
returning to and and we're moving there
really from a a zero sum game to a
non-zero sum
game right there's a winner and loser
and what you do that's why you add I
always think of that you add the
dimensionality and it recasts the game
as not a winning and losing game and
that's what we have to do in GA Theory
right if you want to save the world from
from us we have to recast the game as
the is as the entire game right the the
sustainable development goals even the
UN has them they're even tripping over
them because they have some they had one
power plant they developed the garat
power plant in Bangladesh and and they
scored big score on energy sdg and on
development SG and then they got sued by
the local fishermen in the local
population for pollution which was
screwed them on the other SG they didn't
even talk among the SGS at the UN now
that's not surprising if you know the UN
and the institution but it shows you
that it's even it's hard to integrate
even when you have the the same source
of the Norms or the or the aspirations
they just go for it on one of them and
they don't they're not talking to each
other right
and here's why preventing failure is so
critical um which body is healthier each
organ system at 90% function or most of
them at 99 and one is at zero well y
that body is dead so all of the
functions need to be adequate or better
and we need to improve adequate improve
resiliency improve accessibility Etc but
preventing failure uh cannot be uh just
part of the discussion on reducing risk
reducing cascading failure has to be an
imperative and so in that framework
where we want multiple components to be
functioning it just reframes the oh
should the government be interfering
here or should this person be
undertaking this policy and again like I
said like the task to synchronize on
action might be easier than thought so
those two lumber yards getting them to
go to the same religious institution or
send their children the same education
or listen to the same YouTube channels
why why even go down that road in the
metaphor when you could just offer them
a service where they're drisking their
Lumber business so instead of saying
we'll synchronize these lumber yard
people on this and then they'll just act
nicely together it's like yeah or you
could just provide the interface so that
whoever they are however things change
they'll be able to play nicely together
instead of just saying well if we
synchronize them in this way then
they'll know what to do they won't
because people don't well and that's why
one of the things that I talk to people
about is I say our recruitment that I'm
doing in the program at the lab is not
based on on selflessness it's based on
self-interest and the assertion is that
they can drisk in ways they cannot do
unilaterally period that's what I tell
people and so you get together so it's a
commitment if they want to drisk in
these new ways they can't do it by
themselves just like a stoplight I can't
I didn't send out around a memo saying
let's all stop at the red light that was
done right these are these are scales
that we can't do unilaterally
and so that tempting that bait of saying
you can go over there and like with
swaps Australia swaps were outlawed when
they first came out and the banks in
Australia were getting killed because
they couldn't swap out their interest
rate risk so they lobbied the Australian
government to allow for swaps and then
they did allow for swaps and they were
able to swap out their interest rate
risk like other Banks the downside is
they all then got hurt in 2008 when the
swaps were used for speculative purposes
that's a different problem
but that invitation to drisk in ways you
can't do alone it's kind of it's It's a
crass way of getting people in the space
but to me it's the hook that joins that
left hand side and the right hand side
with those four spheres because you
right on the left hand side you have
this characterization of risk as a zero
sum game on the right hand side well
maybe it's not a zero sum non-zero sum
in that context but it allows for a
bigger the dimensionality of drisking
increases when you increase the system
size so if you get those people who are
similarly situated together it's new
markets that's what trade associations
are right trade associations people are
competing all them potato chips Lumber
it doesn't matter trade Association
competitors get together and what do
they do share information and insurance
those are the two biggie things they co-
insure for some whatever risk they share
andless they can buy insurance cheaper
of whatever kind and they uh and they
also share information so they can
understand situational awareness better
yep I put up the slide here again
um yeah Ivon so you want do you have
anything you want to add or or remark on
no just chilling yeah okay continue
Scott wait weirdly I think we just lost
Scott's audio in between oh no I okay
okay sorry
continue uh but I was thinking I there
was some other thing I was going to say
but I can't remember now about that that
oh yes yes this is an example from the
Fisheries industry so M this Elanor
Ostrom um worked very closely with
people in the Fisheries so a lot of
Fisheries are designed with Ostrum
Notions and um so uh the of the commons
and one of the things that a friend of
mine who works in the um uh hold on a
second okay Stephen any sorry one of the
one of the guys sorry one of the guys
who works in the um fishing industry he
said they had a problem they have this
thing called buy catch and it's the fish
you're not supposed to catch so let's
say I'm going to make up these numbers
in the species but let's say you're
allowed to catch 200,000 pounds of
flounder but they an orange Rockfish or
yellow rockfish and if you catch four
pounds of that you have to stop fishing
it's a protected species you can't fish
anymore you can't pay your bills you
can't buy the oil you can't send your
kids to school you don't you don't have
money so what they did they were trying
to figure out how we going to protect
orange Rockfish or yellow rockfish so
what they did is they said okay let's
pull the allocations of different
Fisheries so if they had three guys each
had a four pound allocation so they can
pull it and make a 12- pound allocation
so they can then what happens is if one
of the one of the people goes out and
fishes and catches five pounds of yellow
rockfish he can still fish whereas he
might in the past have had to stop so he
spread the risk out but then what
happens is the the other fishermen start
to be policemen because they're cutting
into their allocation so they go over
and they say hey hey hey use a differ
Siz net or don't fish in that area
whatever they share information because
he's cutting in it's an economic loss
for all of them because they pulled
their allocation so to me that's a big
deal that that that idea because what
they're doing is they're spreading risk
and when you spread risk it's like
insurance if more people have claims out
there and my premium go up right so I'm
going to encourage things that make
things
safer right as a as a stakeholder in
that system and so similarly here it
feels like when we move to that right
side diagram we're going to have more
Avenues with which to create information
flows among the parties that will
actually drisk better than the left side
and make it cheaper Stephen and then
I'll have a point on
that yeah I think this this this use of
this diagram could be important because
yeah the in a way I suppose this diagram
on the left it's like you either just
put in laws or to to mitigate those
risks and challenges or the
transdisciplinary tool that we have at
our disposal is money money is the thing
that everyone uses basically as the
transdisciplinary allocation of what to
do on projects and it doesn't is it's
Pro highly problematic and there's not
really a lot of other things apart from
what budget gets allocated that allows
that so is there a way that this can
provide us and and and at different
scales because sometimes yeah it's
fairly clean at kind of a national level
or you know you have your rulers level
and the individual but most stuffs
happen in in between as we're talking
about how can we somehow get a handle
which is not too
culturally metaphoric ly uh constructed
but it's is is is maybe relatively
Universal I know it's bad to use that
term but I think there's something in
that in in in being able to say okay
this is how this information gains
happening this is how this you know and
now you're starting to have a way to
talk about um Dynamics um in ways which
aren't normally possible yeah one
thought on that and again to this point
about you want to design the Nexus the
interface in a way that is inclusive and
accessible but respects that not just do
people disagree but they have actually
different visions and understandings
about this whole system that we're in
and so here's and then where we can tie
it to this figure and how it could be Ed
to communicate and maybe even organize
around so on the left side it leads
towards abstraction because it's like
well let's let's wait until we're less
um ambiguous and then once you have no
ambiguity it's like well let's figure
out out what the least risky policy is
but guess what all the policies have
risks and even if there was one that
somehow had less risk than strictly all
the others there's still Black Swan
events and there's still people with
different preferences for uh a given
pipeline for oil or for a given fishing
agreement so the idea that you're going
to minimize risk for all parties in a
way that they're satisfied with is going
to be this Quest that you're going to be
at the the drawing board quite probably
forever let's contrast that with the
right side and you know the the authors
I hope will be okay with us taking wide
latitude because I it's you know we're
taking this figure beyond what y it's
framed but that's what's fun right now
let's go to that drawing board with the
um the power plant and the Fishers and
Ostrum and everything like that instead
of just getting Frozen at the drawing
board on the left so now we're on the
right side and we're saying look we are
at the drawing board so whether we're
speaking through a translator or you
believe that we have different interests
we're here at the Nexus so Universal
aside what's locally going to be working
for our system well we have two
imperatives we want to make maximum
Information Gain but we want to maximize
if you look at that ISO given P it's not
Information Gain on the observations
that's this part see how it's strictly
in the O here's ambiguity about State
observations okay this is maximizing
Information Gain on States and
observations given policy in other words
words we're not just reducing our
ambiguity about states of the world like
give me a more accurate stock ticker
this is like hey what's the most
informative uh policy that we can enact
to learn about the states so we want to
query the markets in a way that isn't
just getting increased Precision on
viewing them and so now we're all at the
table together so whether we believe
ourselves to have or actually have
adversarial interest in one dimension of
300 or all the dimensions or whatever we
have an expansive maximization growth
oriented goal together which is
implementing policy that helps us
understand our system and the mapping
between the hidden States and the
observations better together now by
doing that we're also engaging in joint
action which will prepare us for larger
and better action and what are we doing
joint action to do well part of it is to
be consistent with the kind of system
Who We Believe ourselves to be but the
other part the minimization what we're
running away from the stick is disorder
with respect to the observations so not
with respect to us getting paralyzed
about which policy but we want to reduce
our surprise about our observations in
the context of optimal policy okay so
here how much CO2 is there really in the
world and how much do we really make and
what would be the riskiest policy and
should we just remove gas cars and I
mean you could go down this Rabbit Hole
forever right here is here's a predicted
trajectory here's different types of
models and what they predict about the
trajectory of CO2 levels through time
and we want to reduce our uncertainty
about that model together all kinds of
people who believe different things
we're going to reduce our uncertainty
purely about
observations as we jointly use policy
together to learn more it's just such a
positive way of framing it and again
people are still going to disagree but
we're coming to the table together so as
long as we're not at arms and we're
coming to the table together we don't
need to go Universal we don't need to go
culture free we just say we're here
we're figuring this out today for
ourselves now and for other people
later and when you that's beautiful I
mean I you're I can't wait till I have
more facility with the concepts because
what you're describing the processes
you're describing are going to become
governance it's not like we're going to
find governance of the processes those
processes will be governance that's
going to how it's going to happen and so
it's a very the question is you know
we're we're on the left side how do we
get to the right side what are the
stages that we can do to move us over
there how do we provide uh prepare
ourselves as groups to be able to
function on the right side in a natural
organic kind of way one of the things
that I've been advocating for is
collecting practices from the left side
but then having groups stare at the
practices so you can say okay let's it's
basically making different changing the
assembly right the
disintermediation of the left side has
been done by the Internet it's done by
covid it's done by the big challenges to
those systems they reveal the
limitations of those systems and so the
disintermediation is done on the right
side we're going to reintermediate
because there is still mediation of the
individual components in the system
right they're brought together but we're
reintermediate with a
fundamentally it's it's fundamentally
different in some ways in some ways it's
quite similar and so one of the things
that I'm interested in is trying to find
ways to make it so similar that people
don't even realize you know they or or
they're comfortable with the move to
this new framing of analysis very cool
yeah
Stephen and this this ties in as well
actually this is so good that you've
gone through this diagram it makes makes
it very much jump out but this like the
safe to fail approach of of trying to so
if you imagine that policy wheel um the
red wheel on the on the right hand side
you know
Act of inflence knows that that's really
our choices are what we do with our
policy we we a lot of what's out there
in the world the hidden States you know
we only have so much control over so if
we're able
to almost shift the policies in there
and and knowing that they're safe to
shift so these safe to fail experiments
which is what they talk about with so if
you do safe to fail policies which means
that you can then observe the states
observe the What observations observe
the overlaps observe the Dynamics over
time then you've got an awful lot of um
new information that you can use and
obviously the key is to do not to have
something in there which will be um
there this antifragile comes into that
as well you know so you can learn as you
do and and obviously knowing that there
will be certain times when you got to
pull away and stick to a you know risk
minimization Focus but this you know it
gives a way to talk about that probably
to people from very different views of
the world yep so another metaphor there
with performance would be like a martial
art and the safe to fail and the
sparring and the play so there's times
to play and you know for children and
there's times to be serious but no
matter what you're doing it's always
serious because people can fall if
you're walking you can fall if you're
talking you can say something mean if
you're you know holding data you can
lose the data so everything is very
important and so we need to have that
resilience in mind one other way in
which this can be used so this is um
putting a little bit beside this uh
purely like somebody at the table who
doesn't want to communicate with us
scenario so now we're in a situation
where like people want to work together
at least they've bought on to that level
okay we're talking about the system and
someone just has this figure up you know
just as they do and Stephen you said it
like what we control is policy we
control climate policy you know what we
don't control the climate but what do we
control our climate policy we don't
control biogeochemical cycles we
influence them but we don't control the
outcome and so people could be talking
and someone's like well I want to see
this okay you're talking about C you're
talking about your preference vector and
someone say or are we talking about the
state of the world are you actually
saying that this is how people feel or
are you just stating your preferences
about the world because it's fine if you
want to you know I I want to learn about
your preferences and remember your PR Es
are the key factor that really go into
our policy but our policy is not the
same thing as the states about the world
yeah so it's like okay now what are the
observations someone says no no no
actually it's 80% so okay your your
inference is that this is 80% is that
right well here's this observation oh
well this study is biased okay well
great let's you know what if it was a
factor of two so there's so many ways
just to have this figure up and someone
says are you sure about that policy
selection say Okay W it sounds like up
here it sounds like we're in the
metacognitive World we're thinking
implicitly about our own group's
generative model of this policy decision
making process and it seems like you're
uncertain about this and what are you
uncertain about okay what could we
figure what could we reduce our
uncertainty about is it your preferences
is it the way that your preferences and
our uncertainty are being combined with
the affordances and the niche into
policy that of course is the hardest not
to untie that's control theory and
everything but you can at least say hey
is it your uncertainty is it your
preferences is it the niche perception
affordances not just the preferences but
the niche itself e the prior and is that
being combined in a way that makes sense
to generate policy because if you if you
disagree with the policy which part of
these was it because that's all that
went into it so don't just say you
disagree with a policy tell me do you
want something to be do you value
something that wasn't valued by this
policy okay now that we're talking about
a given policy do we have
synchronization at least cely on the
starting State not on all the details
but at least like the starting state for
our scenario and are we talking about
states of the world do you believe that
our policy is going to influence the
beat you think that the cutting the
miles per gallon to 20 is going to
change the way that the hidden State CO2
in the world changes through time you
think it's going to do that well I don't
think it's going to do that or I you
know think it's going to do this instead
and so now we have an interface okay
policy is how states of the world are
changing not just as a function of
models of prediction but as a function
of our interference in the system and
it's going to be manifested in
observables not just we believe that 80%
of this will be happening by this future
time but rather as a function of policy
we're going to see these observables and
if we're surprised by the observables we
see along the way we're going to be
course correcting and we're going to be
at the same table again so there's so
many actual structural ways to talk
about this I think and and as well as
narratively that people could even
having this up maybe it could be simpler
than this one maybe it could have a few
more pieces but just separating out
where people disagree it's like yeah in
a legal I don't know yeah in a legal
system I could imagine this being useful
too oh well it would have to be recast
as something that people wouldn't you
know fall out of their chair because
legal people don't like to see squiggly
Latin and Greek symbols but but the but
the absolutely no question I mean the
way you described it what you're doing
is you're really mapping I mean it's
teaching and you're and and and and
showing people you know whenever you
have a map that says you are here you
know when you're lost in the zoo or
something like that and really it's a
you are here map right so cge you know
it's it's allowing more granularity and
it's offering more dimensionality for
Solutions right because if people are
just talking about policy there'll be
ambiguity if they're not talking about
CG or E yes yeah what are your
preferences C what what are the field of
affordances e and the prior over those
like the the quote nuclear option it's
an affordance and it's the last resort
so tied up in the affordance is How
likely it is that's your prior over
policies so you have the field of
affordances and the prior about them
then you have your preferences C I want
to see a world where there isn't
radioactive fallout and then you have
your
uncertainty and then those get combined
in a way that is formalized with G and
that relates to Pi policy selection
being the outcome of the free energy
being minimized which is again what's
the most likely policy and someone's
like wait most likely it's like right
but most likely under the model of the
world that you believe will happen not
just the one that you think is like the
run-of-the-mill because quote the
run-of-the mill is not run-of the- Mill
yep it's really interesting because I
mean you're integrating subjectivity
into an analysis of the
reality in a formal
way it has that I believe that this is
where the Dual instrumentalism is the
most powerful thing in the FP zone so
the Dual instrumentalism again it's like
there's it's also kind of like a Bailey
and mot I don't know if that's being
mispronounced but like where there's a
strong and a weak form of an argument so
again the strong claim would be this is
what systems are and this is how they're
um operating that is what a bacteria is
that is what the Marco blanket is but
the actual weaker claim is just we're
going to use it as an instrument it's
like we use linear aggressions to mod in
Time series modeling to model GDP
through time or regression of you know
height versus risk for some disease it's
like it didn't say people are linear
regressions by doing that it did lead to
a world in which certain types of
conclusions were reached but it wasn't
that people were linear models it was
actually consequences so this is just a
different statistical model and as we're
exploring today and we continue to
explore even qualitatively it helps
structure messy discussions about
adversarial relationships and in that
way which we're only barely scratching
the surface of like you know really
formalizing the marov blankets around
companies and things like that having
this type of a structuring and being
able to be uh disambiguous but it could
be so much more it could be translated
between languages it could be versioned
it could have
impartial um you know trust providing uh
groups there's so much that could be
done there and it's funny because so one
of the books I have on the Shelf here is
by hanaman it's called doing money and
it's about how money is a universal risk
consolidator so you know you get money
and you can take care of your other
risks basically so one of the things
I've been wondering about is well money
is kind of turned into Data because you
don't really spend cash anymore so
why can't data itself without being
monetized be a universal
risk um
mitigator Stephen you cracked me up when
you said that money was
transdisciplinary I've never heard you
know people say that transdisciplinary
research but I've never it's so true
though the Departments will pay each
other in money they won't site each
other but they'll pay each other so it's
so true and so and so that but data can
data now be and can this
system because money we we you go to an
airport you got to convert one system
into another so there's different
encoding of the bills themselves right
okay so that's but but ultimately I
always tell people if I walk out of if
I'm outside a courthouse and someone
says I just got a $10,000 judgment I
don't know if it's for a divorce case a
slip and fall I mean it's money it's
$10,000 is identical you can buy the
same amount of groceries but it could be
for various different things that you
were you were compensated right so in
data it feels like this model might
allow us to have data be a medium of
exchange and maybe storage I don't know
I won't go into that right now but a
medium of exchange of risk without
having to go through the monetary
Loop very very
interesting yep I I can kind of imagine
some areas
Stephen and this this might be where
bringing the body back in can help too
as we you know you talk about like
there's there's money in my hand and
there's there's money like we talk about
when you get it for something and then
there's Capital which is almost like an
augmented um cognition process which is
up there in the markets you know that
we've offloaded onto and is very hard to
embody what's going on up there it's
it's like it goes off it does its
calculation it comes back and we do what
I mean half the people doing it are
doing on screens who themselves are
being proxies for other people you know
so there's there's there's a question
about um where this comes back into
ultimate um sense making at different
time scales y yep you Ivan was smiling
before I didn't were you smiling at the
money thing I let's let's maybe have
yeah let's have uh anything you want to
go there Ivon if you want otherwise
let's have a little closing imagin you
and new new money and new money of new
people
yep so maybe we'll have a final set of
thoughts so prepare that but the other
side um Scott of the the money uh
trading in the airport is that uh in a
healthy system every sale is
bidirectionally consensual every
agreement is not feeling forced it's
like so somebody wanted your peso the
other person wanted the Yen so they made
a deal they met in a Marketplace they
wouldn't have found it on Craigslist the
operating cost would have been too high
but somebody wanted it now when does it
become deranged well when there's um
extra Market forces that force people to
do things or when there's um you know
devaluation Market manipulation etc etc
but again it's not like there's a pure
untrammeled Market out there and then
it's like oh regulation how dare they
it's actually we construct the market
it's like we're building the bowl so
it's not just like there's a pure bowl
and then you've defiled it by putting
Clay on it it's like no what is the
structure that you're going to be
interfacing in and can that not just be
imbued with our values which aren't
going to always have justification
they're often acatic but can it actually
allow diverse agents to act according to
their deeply held axioms so that there
is ability of people who have different
faith in different things and it's been
a joke for so long oh you don't need to
believe in the legit the government to
use the currency of a Fiat and now we're
just seeing it in a new light so it's
it's really interesting that market may
be just an emergence from the fact of
information seeking in trades yep and
also leveraging and how that's trust
like there's Bitcoin on the blockchain I
just these are the examples I think
about um yeah but then there's the 10x
leverag Bitcoin who legitimized that
exchange or that person to um offer 10x
leverage or some other type of asset
based upon leveraged on bitcoin nobody
gave that permission if that person or
that operation is reputable um and to
whatever extent it is it will succeed or
hopefully and again anything other than
that is dysfunction so there's a way to
talk about that in a way that is pretty
different from the reward optimization
of different competing agents that's
previous Paradigm reward optimization
competitive agents and we're not just
moving from competitive to to
Cooperative it's actually not that
simple it's actually more about from the
uh reward to the Precision guiding
mindset and that everything else Falls
in line after that and the action and
the Precision are the key pieces some of
the key pieces and so that's the
coherence lending Factor yes we want to
be precise about process together that's
the minimal meme not we're g to have
abundance in the future but today we're
going to have Precision
here yep so it's really yeah it's a it's
a different it's really fascinating the
way it's going to iterate itself into
it's more scalable but it's not yet
scaled y you know I I think of it makes
me think of adaptation studies I have a
book on Cambridge book on adaptation
studies in theater where if you take
Romeo and Juliet and you translate it
into another language you got a lot of
work to do because there's a lot of
phrasing and there's a lot of behavior a
lot of things for adaptation what we're
doing here is is just like a giant
simultaneous
adaptation
vehicle right because everyone's coming
in with priors and this system allows
people to discover things that they have
in common it allows them to act in
common and that's going to have such
huge
power it won't and it won't be something
that will create spaces for it it will
create the space this the interaction
space
will evolve and then be and then it'll
be parameterized in metrics and you'll
know if you're in it or not there'll be
certain behaviors that indicate you're
in it right but it's it's that's why I
always say the process becomes the
governance it's not you don't that's
what a lot of people there's AI problem
right now not R AI but the artificial
intelligence that everyone is trying to
create everyone that I can find is
trying to create systems to govern the
people creating the AI but not the AI
system
itself and I'm thinking more along lines
of azimov which is you need the rules
for the robots themselves similarly here
each one of these systems is a
robot it's not programmed by us per se
but it's caused by us and it has uh
features that are the result of our
desires and needs so it's programmed in
that way corporations are robots I think
they're programmed our constructed Niche
is how we we would consider it it you're
never going to break away it's intertwin
with us it's in our Niche yep go on
right right and so the so it's
interesting because I think a lot of
folks look at
Authority like the Fiat money is I think
the U us is a Fiat not just because of
rule of law but because of a monopoly of
violence we have the most guns and
bombs and so that it's a violent it's
violence and imperialism and all that
stuff that's wrapped up in
Fiat right there's a power there and I
think the power is shifting from
physical violence to other forms of
information I w't use the word violence
here but information Authority and it
feels like the ability of this system to
declare that it can get you closer to
reality continuously it's dynamically
it's like the scientific method it's
dynamically rejiggering itself I
wouldn't say closer to truth I would say
towards a better process together yes
dynamically that's right yep that's
right there's no there is no end state
of Truth yep but that value
proposition is not characteristic of the
current
systems and so it has a unique feature
of D Dr risks in a way that's
much uh more effective than the current
systems it requires people to do the
Cooperative thing which is like I said
with credit cards or ATMs or swaps or
anything with
mitochondria right you know your free-
existing things have to come together
because it's a better deal to be had
right so that's and so that so the
convey our conveying why there's a
better deal to be had we can use the
existing problems in the world climate
change
War it's not even a better deal it's a
better negotiating table yes and that's
that's always the reframe is always from
there will be better states to we're
going to seek Precision today yes
beautiful beautiful and that gets back
to that now versus past and future thing
that I was struggling with before right
we're not going to we're not saying it's
better it's a it's a better way to be
and we don't know where being takes us
because that's we have models of it you
have a model I have a model we have a
model let's get together figure out
where we want to be the reality is the
combin the synthesis of those
desires I guess as evolving Through Time
Clos closing statement from first
Stephen then Ivonne if he want then back
to
Scott well yeah I suppose that the the
takeaway um and there was you had the E
the G what was the third letter again
there was um C is the preference Okay C
I think that's really useful I think
that's like a nice meeting point there
between and I keep going back to this
but ergodicity and noner it in the sense
that you know as you get down to the
smaller scales the body and I think even
when you get into this Outsider
cognition everything's got to follow
that growth kind of erodic kind of churn
and then you start to have this ability
to bring in these non- erodic as we get
to larger time scales and you know we
even see as we get now to the state and
how you can borrow money in ways which
an individual can't we've seen this with
the EU because they're not constrained
by lifespan in the way that mortgage
mortages are and so you've got this
weird ability to bring in preferences in
that um about of nonergodic sort of ways
of just making a choice and creating
deliberately steady state like a fe
currency the whole point is it's steady
and non erodic but we actually and this
is where I think a lot the work with the
indigenous cultures is they are they
could say they're trapped in the old
cyclical way of understanding the world
but actually that gives you a way to
tune into your deeper existential way of
knowing about the long-term future
because that is where your phenotype
knowledge comes from not um you know the
okay we have these structures that give
us this ability to also do deep temporal
depth but we do lose the ability to
integrate free energy in such a new the
dimensions come down and down and down
and down to these kind of artifacts so
yeah this is anyway this is what is
coming up for me thanks well I hope
Stephen that you and others can in the
future you know listen back to what
you've laid out and hopefully see it in
a broader perspective what you were
hinting at Ivonne any closing thoughts
for 2020
indeed yeah sure I just want to thank
you all for brilliant discussion and
it's the great discussion for the of
this uh strange
Year and I hope to see you all next next
from the beginning from the
January and thanks for your help in the
project from the beginning really
critical yeah so very chill Scott
closing thought you guys are this is
this is beautiful you guys are beautiful
this is awesome I'm I feel like a
metamorphosis I'm I'm I'm I'm GNA pupate
a little bit and then I'm going to come
out after the New Year's and be ready to
fly with you guys this is this is really
delightful and fascinating and I think
it's going to be really um very helpful
to a lot of problems that are out there
in the world it feels like there's a lot
of um uh solution space that gets opened
up with this and in in introducing it in
in digestible chunks so I always talk to
my clients about where are you now now
where do you want to be that's a tough
one and and now I see why it's a tough
one because it's in a way the wrong
question where do you where do we want
to be individually and then how do we
synthesize and then what are the ways to
get there and then you triage them so
that's a standard thing I used to use
now that's changing because it's a um
the exploration of where we want to be
is the answer to that really hard second
question which is people have difficulty
answering so thank you for inviting me
on the journey this is great stuff so to
close um on that um Scott you
just you laid out a helpful way of
thinking about it with just where do you
want to go this is common goal setting
who are we where do we want to go how
are we going to get there but you
brought in two pieces which is the
values the values are what is not
explicitly described but they're part of
the preference and the policy and so
combining all of these disperate threads
together and not having one Heat engine
for the refrigerator and one power plant
for the other one but combining all of
these threads together so we can have a
discussion from multi-perspective so
that's the Intercultural component
multi-perspective but also bringing
together these coextn values that we
have for system function
exploration so many other features but
really um my closing thought is for this
live stream that uh tomorrow probably
I'm going to record a video called 12.0
that is going to be the clock striking
midnight on 2020 and then we will indeed
head into a very exciting 2021 and
Beyond so uh both of you uh well
actually all of you I guess are uh RSD
for the active inference lab so I'm just
really looking forward to those three
projects and just like you said Scott
with the digestible bits live live
stream has been our learning process
we've all learned so much along this
journey but now we all also want to be
thinking about kic shorter content ones
that have interactive Parts who knows
but there's going to be yeah great
things happening ahead so thanks
everyone who's listening live or in
replay thanks guys for
participating fantastic and and happy
New Year to everybody yeah happy year
happy New
Year wow what a discussion what a
discussion all right well I'm going to
to terminate the live stream so thanks
everyone and I will talk to you later